i want him to sue me i would love for
him to sue me
i saw this guy on facebook claiming that
dan had stopped
stolen stuff yep and i was like what is
this
kind of who am i getting in bed with
kind of thing he has to know that he did
this
and i just thought you know i didn't
know whether i was going to bring it up
but i just thought you know since we're
just being honest
i just bring it up right now you you are
absolutely correct
if it ever gets out then i am you know i
can be held in the court of law you know
for anything i see or do right this
clear
belligerent over-the-top content factory
let's back up a bit first of all why are
we even talking about the subject
whether dan stole from another
entrepreneur or not
because we live in a world right now
where it's easier to get ahead if you
copy
if you cheat if you plagiarize and i for
one hate it
it's why i called out siraj raval when
he played drives that's why i called out
kevin david i've been on a bit of a
crusade against these people
these so-called experts who get ahead by
taking other people's work
reformatting it to look slightly
different and then calling it their own
i despise it and look i'm not talking
about you know someone being inspired by
someone else's work
no i'm talking stealing word for word or
you know
formatting a few things and calling it
your own so that's the spirit of this
video plagiarism is not okay and with
that said let's talk about what all the
drama is right now with dan lok so
another entrepreneur named alex charfin
recently made a facebook post where he
claimed that dan had stolen the
framework of what he called
the billionaire code which he says is
his life's work
he then claimed that dan took that and
reappropriated it for one of his upsells
you said you said that the billionaire's
code was your life's work would you say
that's actually a fair
is not even an exaggeration not an
exaggeration at all i've been a
consultant and a coach i'm 47 years old
i started as a consultant when i was 21
years old it's it's literally over 20
years of work let's just look at these
two images okay
these two images right here of alex's
billionaire code
and dan lok's what he calls the dragon
100 path
i've got to admit i see his point they
have so many similarities i mean it's
harder to find differences than
similarities
layout they both have nine phases of
entrepreneurship they both have the same
like buckets from you know 0 to 40k 40k
to 100k all these kind of things the
only difference seems to be like the
tiny stuff
like literally the names of the buckets
what alex calls a seeker dan calls a
dreamer
even the follow-up material like giving
the profiles of these people is eerily
similar check it out
and i asked alex if he was willing to
call it stealing
and it wasn't a team member this wasn't
this wasn't a mistake this wasn't an
accident this is
clear belligerent over-the-top content
theft
now here's the crazy part all of this is
for something he calls the dragon 100.
dragon 100 is where i advise and consult
with
seven and eight figure entrepreneurs and
from what i could tell it's dan's
highest upsell now here's the thing
i wanted to confront dan's team about
this but obviously they're not just
going to come on the show i've invited
him many a time
although the invitation is still out
there so what i did instead is i got on
a consulting call using an
alias ben doverson and dan's right hand
man
desmond soon picked up now bear in mind
i have nothing against this guy he seems
to have drank the kool-aid just as much
as anyone but i have nothing to lose so
after a little bit of small talk i come
out and just ask about alex charvin and
bear in mind he doesn't know
who i am and this is what he says i saw
this guy
on facebook claiming that dan had
stopped stolen stuff
yep and i was like what is this who
kind of who am i getting in bed with
kind of thing
and i just thought you know i didn't
know whether i was going to bring it up
but i just thought you know since we're
just being honest
i just bring it up to you right now you
you are absolutely correct
right so because you brought it up i
have to give you the official
legal response okay and and here goes
allow me to read it out to you
okay thank you for your recent inquiry
about this situation
please note that we do not generally
respond or comment
to any posts or claims that have not
been proven through proper legal
channels uh we are closely following the
post and have redirected all trails of
correspondence to a legal council
our council will review and investigate
the legitimacy and validity of such
claims
and that's all i you know i have to give
you the the official
uh response to that
so he starts with the legal answer but
then after that
i think i said i was some social media
person or something he confides in me
and goes yeah from one social media guy
to another this is what i really think
you know if it ever gets out
then i am you know i can be held in the
court of law you know for anything i say
or do right
uh but i just think it's you know this
is just my personal opinion i just think
it's childish what he's doing
it's a strategy it's a black hat social
media strategy i think you as a social
media manager know this kind of stuff
i've always chosen to do white hat stuff
how is with alex charvin doing black hat
and what he's doing white hat what kooky
upside down world are we living in right
now how
how is dan somehow the victim here but
desmond goes
on and he admits that these designs are
very similar because how could you not
but seems to blame it on a person you
know someone from dan's team oh this was
this couldn't have been dan no it's not
dan
uh when you get big you know it is very
obvious
that uh alex and dan stuff look alike
whether or not maybe one of our members
on our team that was helping to put
together the frameworks and and the work
for that obviously
you know dan doesn't build his own stuff
anymore right he doesn't need to he just
tells the team hey here's the project
here's what i need
and so maybe our graphics designer
person you know leverage that was
inspired by it
oh he was i was inspired by it
i this is what
inspired by looks like these days you've
got to be kidding me
i forgot to mention that there's another
piece of evidence
sort of definitively showing a lot of
this stuff
or at least they convinced me uh this is
an
early version i'm flipped here this is
an early version of the dragon 100 path
where they were testing it out this is
before they kind of
i guess tried to hide what they did they
had
almost identical icons up here the same
that alex charfon did i mean it's so
close
look at this magnifying glass magnifying
glass this takes inspiration to another
level rocket
rocket handshake handshake so this isn't
even the concept it's not just the
concept that was taken
it's not just even the bar graph it's
not just the buckets it's like
down to the graphics and it drives me
crazy that these corporations
act psychopathic when it comes to this
stuff like normally when somebody's
caught
this red-handed they'll admit it or
they'll apologize or something
and it seems like dan lok's
organization's strategy is to up we'll
just say
legal hey legal we don't know i guess
we'll i guess it'll be to be determined
at such time that it's determined as
such time
dude everyone knows what you're doing
and everyone knows what that means
come on get real i mean for me just
personally for my values this is
disgusting and look i mean to play it
fair here all this stuff about dan not
being involved or being involved
maybe it's true but this little idea of
it being an intern or a graphic designer
or whoever
either way it's dan's product it's dan's
top product from what i can tell like
take accountability man
if it's straight ripped off of someone
else whether or not dan actually copied
it himself
he sure presented it you better believe
it check it out what i'm gonna walk you
through
is a powerful framework so i call this
the dragon 100 path and there are nine
stages stage number one like either dan
presented it and he's lazy and just
didn't bother
checking like where did you guys get
this stuff and he's just not creating
any of his own stuff or he knew
either way it's bad this is what you're
paying top dollar for if you go with dan
lok
i think dan's only way forward is to
take full accountability on this one and
just say
dude i messed up um and you know if he
doesn't
i think it signals to everyone what type
of business man he is and again
you know i played this clip literally
yesterday but it's so timely
old joey diaz from the joe rogan
cinematic universe he was talking about
brian rose but you could literally
apply it directly to dan today and it
would sound
and ring just as true check it out
instead of this guy sending me an email
going bro i'm sorry
he keeps telling me it's his interns
that's what i got pissed off about
because claim responsibility even till
today he put up a youtube video on
monday
saying that it was his interns that guy
you never want to do business with a guy
like that
that cannot claim responsibility that's
the type of guy that'll leave you in a
[ __ ]
now no matter what you think of this
case i think it's time we clean
house with the bad actors in this
industry and start calling out people
when people steal when they take other
people's ip i mean what do you guys
think
let me know in the comments below and as
always don't forget to smash
like and subscribe thank you
[Music]
[Music]
comes along